I still don't believe in myself to do
the next thing I'm the believe guy well
I believe in myself to do this but to do
the next thing that's the struggle so
it's a constant how do I believe in
myself to do the next big thing well how
do I then teach belief well because I'm
helping people get to where I'm at I'm
helping people do the things that I had
to overcome because 19 year old Evan who
struggled with everything that launches
business is a lot further behind than 42
year old Evan who's sitting right here
this is my reality here's the mistakes I
made here's the flaws that I have this
is just me but I want to be this but you
got to take that first step and I think
people get so overwhelmed by the thought
of how much they're going to have to do
that they don't even start yeah yeah and
people take a decade to take the first
step and I think that applies to all
areas physical mental spiritual health
whatever but every day you have to take
a little step in each direction do your
doc in Next Step mode all the time and I
think that's normal we'll go through
these modes we'll have exact Clarity
what we want to do and we're going we
chase that down and then it's not
interesting anymore and you may not know
what you want to do next and so now
we've we've got to experiment and try
and then you find the next thing and you
go blinders and focus on that like I
don't think anybody wakes up and just
does the same thing their entire life
and loves it
I have intense men let's go man what do
you got look at how fancy I like it
driving in from Pittsburgh to be here we
made it I told you I was going to get
here one way or the other yeah I love it
it's great I don't know was it three
three years ago four years ago yep
what's interesting about being here was
five years ago when I started when I
decided to stop drinking get healthy get
sober I was a stress drinker so I didn't
really know what to do
um
I just knew that I couldn't continue to
watch and listen to what I was doing
politics and stuff like that so I went
to YouTube and the first thing I could
think I didn't know of anybody to look
for so the first thing I did was I typed
Tony Robbins and I said for the first
couple months I was listening to the
don't jump videos like the Rock Bottom
stuff and as I was doing that I see a
yellow and black thumbnail
and then I see your name I'm like Evan
there's not a lot of us out there who is
this right yeah you gotta say that I was
a little bit annoyed like right like I'm
annoyed like no no I'm like I'm you know
I'm heaven
so then I started watching your your
content I'm like I know I'm older than
this guy you know and um so I started
watching your content and I was I got
into like your top tens and
um every morning I would start my day
with it and I would get up and I would
read and I'd pray and I'd meditate and
stretch and then I would put on
something of yours and that's how I
learned who a lot of these people are
that now I follow and read books or
whatever
and then um and then it progressed from
like the the don't jump stuff to more of
the personal development and whatever
and um then you did your tour
and then I found you in Pittsburgh and
you know my whole objective was that
snowy night and I think it was January
it's crazy dude yeah and I and I I think
when I when I walked up to you I said
I'm not really here for anything other
than say thank you because you had a big
part in my sobriety journey and you
didn't even know it because I relied
heavily on the content that you made and
then saw you again in in Cleveland and
then you know here we are today but
what's interesting is I found you from
watching looking up at Tony Robbins yet
two weeks ago I was in Florida and
finally got to see his event live and
then the message went out that you guys
were doing this and that's why I jumped
on it so I would look for him and found
you and then when I was with down there
watching him it led me to come back and
actually meet you up here so it kind of
came like full circle I love it dude
yeah
so
so what do you got how can I help what's
on your mind what's the next level
you know I had a whole bunch of
questions that I was going to ask you
and then
um what hit me in that conversation was
I think the biggest obstacle is
how does and for me and for others how
does a person for lack of better terms a
broken person
get over that to be able to help other
people that might be
when they themselves haven't healed yet
that's how I feel like how do you if you
you don't feel qualified to do it
um
I think that's been my biggest my
biggest
um
I don't know what the word would be um
that's been I think what's
subconsciously been holding me back the
most of I know I've been through a lot I
know that I have a story I know that
I've overcome a lot but I'm not yet
where I want to be and there's a lot of
things that I haven't forgiven myself
for so I feel like because I haven't
found that reconciliation
how do I help other people do what I
have not been able to do to this point
what a way to start I love it dude uh so
a couple things in there and this is
stuff that helped me I don't know how
prescriptive it is you can take what
works and leave what doesn't for me
serving is part of the healing process
so
for me to heal and get better
I need to be helping others right so you
saw me on that tour
Pittsburgh was if it wasn't our first
stop was one of our first jobs was
number one first stop and then you went
to Cleveland the last stop and you saw
the difference between me Cleveland I
had my I had a broken neck I don't know
if you stuck away to the end like that I
was on the floor for 45 minutes just at
the end because like I was I was gone I
gave everything
but we had a real decision when I when I
had broken my neck like do I keep going
or go home and everybody was saying go
home like it's crazy you go home
everybody would understand if you go
home because you broke your neck you
could concussion all this but for me
I would get more healing by being with
people and helping them than me being on
the couch at home
just healing or feeling sorry for myself
or whatever and I had all sorts of
you know I was I was gaining lots of
weight because I wasn't moving around I
had like this giant scab on my forehead
I wasn't thinking as clearly as I
normally would be the events were worse
right I wasn't I didn't have the same
energy you saw me at the end in
Cleveland but I still didn't have as
much energy there as I did in Pittsburgh
when I first started because I I wasn't
moving around sitting there for four
hours with ice packs on me but that
became part of my healing process so for
me I actually healed more by being with
people and sitting with them and helping
them than by me being by myself I
haven't gone through any serious
depression or I haven't wanted to commit
suicide and some of the things that you
know you've talked about but one of my
favorite Expressions that I forget who
said it was like don't suffer alone you
know like when you're when you're alone
just and you when you're suffering sorry
just don't be alone reach out to
somebody have have a community have a
group have a friend so you're not by
yourself because you're you can do
stupid things when you're by yourself
when you're really in really dark places
and you've you pulled yourself off the
edge you know in there which is amazing
amazing but a lot of people don't
you're never fully healed I don't think
but you gain more healing as you
continue to help people at least that's
what I tell myself and what I find works
for me
for the whole like imposter syndrome
thing I don't know if I'm good enough
because I haven't fully solved it well
you can't help people with something
that you haven't fixed
but
Evan tins been today compared to having
tinsman five years ago
right like the weight difference the gun
to your head the alcoholism like you
like you're an impossibility to him
right like Evan tinsman from five years
ago look at this guy's eighth you ran in
Iron Man you're doing these events like
this there's no way you would believe of
what you actually become right like if
you showed yourself a picture of a it's
a five-year-old you right like there's
no way I'm not gonna do that there's no
way I can be that guy and yet you've
done it so you're already an
impossibility to who you used to be
so you can teach people to get out of
that hole like the things that you
haven't solved yet cool that's your
ongoing Journey you're never done here
I've never done healing and learning and
growing and improving
to The Next Step but everything that
you've done which is a lot you've done
the hardest work
that's where most people are stuck
they're stuck at Step Zero
you can help them get to step 20 because
you're at step 21 right you're not
accept eight thousand cool like you
learn and you're growing
but the goal isn't to help people with
things that you like that you should
feel like an imposter if you're trying
to teach people to do something that you
haven't done like I can't help somebody
who's in depression I can listen I could
have empathy I can hold space for them
but I can't say like you should go and
do this
because I haven't been there so like I
should feel like an imposter telling
somebody how to get out of depression or
suicide or any of those things but lack
of belief
I've been there like massive physical
pain I've been there so I can help
people through the things that I've been
through so the goal becomes to go
through more things experience more so
you can then go and teach and serve and
help
but you have tons to share
like I think back to Pittsburgh when you
came there's the event but then we had
the three
people afterwards and you're one of the
three people came the next day and you
spent most of your time helping
everybody else even on your time like
Evan how can we help you you still turn
into how you
I can help the other people who are
there right which is great you got a
huge heart it's amazing
um but you definitely have a ton to
share
and don't pretend to share things that
you don't know how to share and serve
because you haven't gone through it
but most of what you've been through is
like that's the hardest step people who
are going to AAA programs or any of
those things they would they would be
super inspired by what you've done
yeah the um the community piece that
that's another challenge that I've been
dealing with I've kind of befriended
some people and when I did it I kind of
um
like White Knuckle that I did it myself
I mean I had a good therapist I got
professional help from medication but I
didn't do group stuff I didn't do like
the steps in AAA and whatever and
because it didn't work for you
well I didn't try it I didn't go that
path initially it was
um I think just kind of being ashamed of
it
um not wanting to be public having a
business you know a small town everybody
kind of knows me and I just and I found
a path that worked for me
but I also realized that that hurt me
because I've become friends with a lot
of people that went the other direction
they have huge community and they're
always with people and around people and
I found the way I went more of the
one-on-one with my own therapist
whatever that as good as that was I
never got to actually build or be part
of a community
you know so then I I kind of feel like
well at this point to go out I don't
even know where to go from that starting
point so now it's kind of changing a
little bit getting to know people but
realizing that the way I went was kind
of an anomaly and
um
it's hard to connect to the other people
that have gone the other direction so
when I've gone through it myself from
the individual standpoint not realizing
how rare or difficult that is to do and
I'm very fortunate I was be able I was
able to do that
well then to go out and take that to
other people too it kind of contradicts
you know there's there's two worlds
there yeah I mean yes and no
um I think somebody who's already come
out on the other side and they found AAA
or group or Community work as a thing
that helped them cool it doesn't mean
that you can't connect with them you
just may not be able to connect with
them on the solution but in terms of the
pain that they went through you can
connect with them what led them to
be in that group in the first place what
led them to alcoholism you can share
stories about stress drinking and
everything that is Legend maybe you have
a darker story than what they had maybe
I don't know but you can still connect
with them on those things
you may not connect with how they got
out of it
but there's still lots of connection
points if you want
um even though I don't know how you feel
now about you know where you're
struggling or if if you still think
about having a drink every now and then
or when it's super stressful your like
anxiety to the max is does this thought
still come up that I want to go get a
drink like does that still pop up
for the most part I'm good good and it's
good in the areas where I know it's
going to be there like if I'm going out
to eat or going on vacation like you
know it's going to be there but I
actually had I had an incident happen
about a month ago I went I was in
Detroit for a business trip and we ended
up going into like a social event which
didn't realize was going to happen and
it was just like just social like hors
d'oeuvres and whatever and they had a
bar set up and that really got me
because back in my Corporate America
days that's how I um
that's how like you mingle you socialize
you get to know people you network and
that was an environment that I thrived
in and that's the first time in my five
years that I found myself in that
scenario like you know it's going to be
in a restaurant you know it's going to
be a friend's house you know it's going
to be on vacation I did not know it was
going to be on that business trip and I
found myself in an environment for the
first time in five years where I really
enjoyed being to the point that you know
the friend that I was with he looked me
he's like do we need to leave and I'm
like no I'm okay so yeah it made me
realize how fragile it is or how fragile
I am that there is that slippery slope
you know and having an addictive
personality
you know there there's healthy
addictions but that can also be
unhealthy because if you obsess too much
you know whether it's trying to do an
Iron Man or or you know I've taken off
skydiving or or different things like
that it can become unhealthy too so
um
I I guess it's kind of like
um instead of chasing that dopamine now
I try to find it in the process but it's
it's where I feel I can control that
process so you know like
in in in doing a triathlon I say in the
past the old Evan would have been
chasing the metal as the shiny object
full while knowing it wasn't going to
give me the dopamine that I needed so
then you look for the next dopamine hit
but you expect that now that I'm healthy
and I work with my therapist with like I
know that this is going to happen so I
consciously
um try to enjoy the process the growth
was in the process I mean I had
breakdowns and there were moments that I
was just push myself so hard that out of
nowhere I had these emotional outbursts
where I would just start crying like on
my bike and on my runs and like not it
was just it was emotion so I said the
growth was in the process the metal just
proved I did the work so you can
anticipate that that scenario where I
walked into a room I was blindsided
there was no preparation there was no
anticipation and then all of a sudden
like it's right there so that struggle
is there but it can also be on the
healthy side too
because if you have that
that I crashed after not literally like
after I finished my race you know um the
next day I was like well what now the
training's done yeah so then you start
looking and in the triathlon World they
say the only way you can overcome that
is you have to sign up for your next
race and from an addiction standpoint
you have to keep doing what you're doing
until you find something to replace it
because otherwise if you're not moving
forward you're moving backwards because
there isn't a status quo
especially with addiction because you're
looking for external things to fill
internal voids and the external things
are never going to give you what you
want
but from a healthy standpoint you want
to keep moving you in the right
direction are you struggling more with
because we've touched on two topics one
is like community and connection to
people and the other is serving and you
know not feeling good enough or have
having progressed enough to serve and
help people
what's more important to you right now
is like finding the community and
connection to people or taking what
you've been through and serving others
it would be to help people from either
making the mistakes I did
or
um
showing them how to put the pieces back
together after I can't help you in the
middle because I'm not a doctor I'm not
a therapist you know I'm not a
professional in that sense
so if I can derail somebody from hitting
that rock bottom but that's kind of hard
to do if you're already on that down
slide you know for someone to kind of
Step In sometimes you have to hit that
rock bottom but you're more concerned
with serving and helping people than you
finding a community and connecting of
course okay well yeah yeah it's so it
for me it's on the other side I kind of
stick to the the line of like um you're
never too old and it's never too late to
start over and even though I I struggle
with that internally being 47 years old
I mean I was 37 when I started 42 when I
hit my rock bottom and pretty much had
to rebuild every part of my life and
um
so fast forward life is good
but it's hard for me not to regret
losing the five years I feel like I lost
five years of my life and and trying to
make up for it and then I have that I do
have those days where I'm like oh well
you know you're 47 statistically life is
half like
you're too old or you know I have that
internal battle and um and then I go
back and I think this conversation we
had where I said you know it's about
your next step and you actually put the
idea and you said no it's about your
first step so I've really stuck with
that and I I've kind of taken the
approach of like not your first step in
terms of like the program of recovery
but
where you are to where you want to go no
matter what it is each day you have to
take the first step whether it's
Financial relationship spiritual
physical whatever but it starts with the
point of status of like well you have to
be honest and true to yourself that like
well this is my reality here's the
mistakes I made here's the flaws that I
have
um this is just me but I want to be this
but you got to take that first step and
I think people get so overwhelmed by the
thought of how much they're going to
have to do that they don't even start
yeah yeah and then people take a decade
to take the first step right and that's
where and I think that applies to all
areas physical mental spiritual health
whatever but
every day you have to put a little you
know take a little step in each
Direction
you know and that's where I believe
people get lost in that so from my
standpoint I did go all in I was so
desperate to
um I was so desperate financiers I would
have done anything tried anything
because I just I did not decide that I
wanted to get sober I decided that I
didn't want to die you know I decided
that I wanted to live and I try to take
HD like that you know just max out and
and take advantage and try new things
and drive to Canada on a whim let's go
you know but that does change day to day
of what you have to do and and
and I think that's where people
get overwhelmed with it and I think
that's where I can help of like it's
okay to have all of these areas that are
mass if you just put a little bit of
water in each bucket each day you can't
go all in on one because you're going to
waste it and that is difficult when you
have to fix your money fix your
relationships fix your health you know
fix your depression your anxiety deal
with the demons that kind of put you
there in the first place and I think
that's what's haunting me the most like
I haven't reconciled that I still fight
those demons throughout life and some of
them I'm just not public about because
it doesn't need to be
and I think that is where that
insecurity comes from of like
you want to help other people but you're
not sure how to help other people
because you haven't yet figured out
those internal struggles that are
bothering you the most
well hold on that's what's bothering the
most right now
but Evan from five years ago was dealing
with different demons
like you don't have the demon
hounding you every day saying I want to
kill myself
that that existed five years ago maybe
not every day but that was that was
there like that that demon might even be
bigger than whatever you're dealing with
right now and you you may not have like
a 100 killed it but like 99.9 The days
you're not waking up saying I'm gonna
kill myself today yeah that that was
actually that was to clarify that that
was one day
um
and it was a it was that Rock Bottom
moment and for anybody that is dealing
with that it's um
it's a depression thing it's it's the
it's not it's not the person it's the
influence of the substance it just kind
of wears you down to the point that that
you don't um you don't think logically
or rationally and then but you for the
most part beat that demon
yeah it's um so to that extent
absolutely but so but like that's the
point like if you're in the first step
business
you don't have to take people all the
way
you can help people get the first step
to beat that demon right whatever demons
you're still facing now
if you want to share them and make them
public and that's part of your journey
then you can help other people through
those too cool and when you conquer
those ones there'll be other demons that
show up or a bigger version of it right
like me I still don't believe in myself
to do the next thing
I'm the believe guy well I believe in
myself to do this right but to do the
next thing
that's the struggle so it's a constant
how do I believe in myself to do the
next big thing
and it's being able to marry well I can
well how do I then teach belief well
because I'm helping people get to where
I'm at I'm helping people do the things
that I had to overcome because 19 year
old Evan who struggled with everything
that launched his business is uh there's
a lot further behind than 42 year old
Evan who's sitting right here
so you can help people
just the demons that you're facing right
now you can't help people through I mean
I don't know what it is and it's fine
you don't have to I can tell you it's
it's self-acceptance and it's um
itself forgiveness it's the uh right now
for me it's the inability to to
reconcile some of the things I did in my
past and some of the people that I hurt
it's where I'm at now and I don't know
if that's whether it's about I don't
know if that's about guilt or shame and
um and I know those are two very
different things but you already have
more self-acceptance now than you did
five years ago of course but I don't
know if it's to the point that I feel
and I know I mean we've talked about
this of of
being able to go out and to help and to
share that message and get that message
out there you know knowing and doing are
two different things you know so it's
kind of like I know the logical side of
it but to actually Implement and do it I
guess is different
um it's connecting emotionally back to
Old Evan and then I and then I do have
the the practice side of like how do I
get it out there and that's you know
something I need to figure out the ways
to get it out there to where people
would hear it on the scale that I would
like it to be like I've local community
I've I've helped some people which I'm
you know I'm thankful for
um but to get the message out there more
until the Y is figured out the how does
it matter right right you have the best
strategies but unless you're emotionally
committed to it like if you're feeling
like you don't have a good enough story
to share or who am I I'm still fighting
these demons and you can have the best
house but you're not going to do
anything right
so you're you're right now struggling as
Evan tinsman in The Next Step you're in
the next step business and not even like
the next step you're like the next next
next step you're in like step 20.
to figure out self-acceptance and I
don't know that anybody ever figure has
the Dalai Lama figured out
self-acceptance I don't know
like do you ever figure it out I don't
know I don't know probably not so like I
haven't figured it out you know I'm
better than I used to be and that's the
goal and I want to get even better and
maybe somebody helps unlock or the right
video or book or Mentor or whatever
experience but you're never fully done
and you you never want to be fully done
like that's part of the growth Journey
so if nobody ever figures it out then
imagine if Tony never taught because he
didn't have and maybe still doesn't have
full self-acceptance that probably plays
into an addictive personality where
you're always chasing the next or it's
not enough or you don't feel
good enough you know I would imagine it
falls it falls into that you know that
constant Chase of dopamine of wanting
better and it does it goes that you know
external things to fill internal voids
so it's you know
I've often wondered like well even me
being public about my sobriety and
trying to the the weight loss the
trainings the the anything that I do
I think it's
putting it out there forces me to hold
myself to a higher standard because I
don't want to fail in front of other
people where I know some people want to
keep it very private you know whatever
whatever works for you
and then part of it is I am trying to
convey that message of like well yeah I
have lost 72 pounds yeah my my first
goal when I got healthy was like I'd
really like to run a 5k because I've
never done that and now you know I'm
doing Iron Man triathlons and training
to do more so it's the example
but I don't know if I'm doing it more
for myself or for other people or both
if it's combination
it's definitely both like you never I
forget what if you just came back from
Tony so he's got his uh six human
desires there's eight human security and
security and then like the highest level
is right what are the highest two I
don't remember you just came with the
event it was four days uh anyway like
you're ultimately it becomes about
service silence but you're never fully
there right like there's always I think
there's both like if you can if you can
tell yourself that running this marathon
is going to serve other people and I can
show people like Evan tinsman from five
years ago wouldn't have run down the
driveway and now he's out doing a
triathlon right that it could be of
service and helping people and it's also
a personal ego self-confidence like
prove to myself that I can do it chasing
the next high growing learning like
you're not going to be the guy who just
sits on a couch and just accepts his
life and does the same thing for the
next 40 Years of your life like you'll
hear your life you have to you have to
be learning and growing and progressing
and doing something and I think even the
people who are the most like altruistic
for the people that still for I love
helping people it's great I want to
serve the world and this is the ego
selfish like it's I love having my
YouTube plaque and I love you know like
doing the things that like it's nice
it's great so I don't think it's ever
you ever get to 100 maybe maybe the
Dalai Lama was figured out with some
Bonkers figured it out I don't know
um but I wouldn't hold it like unless I
can be 100 here then I'm not gonna start
and do anything right right like you
took a unique approach AAA didn't work
for you cool
there are other people who could learn
from that who like feel they don't have
a path because AAA doesn't feel right
for all the same reasons it didn't feel
right for you I have a business I'm
known
whatever right and so you you don't have
to be prescriptive to say this is what
you must do
you're sharing your story here's what
worked for me
what worked for me as a South therapist
so I still did the work but it was with
one person instead of with a group and I
could afford to have a therapist you
know maybe people can you became very
regimented and like you wake up when you
have your routine and you do your
journaling and you have your process
that you go through and that schedule
helped keep you on the path right right
so again you can share what is your
schedule the common most common question
I get asked often is what's my morning
routine people want to emulate schedules
like well don't use my exact one
but even anybody if you think back to
Evan from five years ago any kind of
morning routine it doesn't involve
waking up and drinking it's like it's a
good thing right and I don't do that
morning routine because in hindsight I'm
like that's what I had to do though yeah
you know it was three and a half four
hours before I even started my day I was
up 3 34 in the morning
until 7 30 but because I was I was
really
um triggered by stress I had to do that
start training my brain to be able to
handle stress to be in a better State of
Mind to go through my days but that's
the first step like when you break your
leg you have crutches right and a cast
right
and ultimately you lose the cast and the
crutches hopefully you learn how to walk
right so that was your crutch or your
cast to get you through that period And
as that time got less and I didn't have
to and that was only maybe one hour half
hour and I could get my meditation or
whatever done
um
well that still leaves that void of like
well I should be or could be doing
something or am I it's that fear of
going backwards like I should be doing
more I need to be doing more and I think
that's why the training regiment and
getting a coach for right now it appeals
to me you know from the the sports the
the triathlon stuff and I realized it
until I replace it I have to keep doing
it that also gives me a release too
because
like my businesses are going well and
growing and and you know I'm pretty good
at it but deep down inside I know it's
not what I really want to be doing but I
have to do it you know
um and then finding that balance of how
do you get that message out even though
the Casual ways I'm putting it out is
generating business because people
follow the story and then they'll say oh
I didn't realize you did that can you
help me with this so it does work
but on a small local scale
you know so it's about you have I take
all this time from a daily work business
standpoint trying to figure out how do I
separate it
to get it on its own you know and and I
think that's kind of where it stalled
for me it's still just the belief that
that the message is worth sharing
and that you're a worthy messenger
you're constantly like I still love the
first step Next Step because you're
stuck in Next Step mode all the time for
yourself uh and I think that's normal
you know like we'll go through these
modes that we'll we'll know we'll have
exact Clarity what we want to do and we
go and we chase that down and then
and then uh it's not interested anymore
and you may not know what you want to do
next right and so now we've we got to
experiment and try and then you find the
next thing and then you go blinders and
focus on that like I don't think anybody
wakes up and just does the same thing
their entire life and loves it so you're
constantly stressed out about or they do
continue to do it and end up an
alcoholic because replicas are not
fulfilled yeah drug addicts like right
hate suicide like at least a really
negative pass so there are moments when
you have the clarity you had your
Triathlon Clarity I'm getting the
triathlon done
uh it serves a benefit also you're
getting healthier but it's a nice shiny
thing to go out and Chase down cool now
you did it okay well now what right so
and it's but that's normal
you know like it's normal to then figure
out okay well what's my next step I
don't know what I want to do so you go
through these periods where you have to
explore and try a bunch of stuff and see
what ends up sticking and then you'll
find the next thing and you go off I
think that's normal it may be more you
know for an addictive personality that
like you need that next thing but it's
still the next step like you're on step
20 and you figure out the next step Next
Step Next Step Next Step but you can't
let that prevent you from helping people
with the first step
right because all the things that you
went through was teachable
and and is practical and valuable and
people who don't feel like they fit in
AAA
you're given an alternative you're not
saying AA sucks you're not saying a
doesn't work right it just didn't work
for you or who you were then you weren't
ready for it for all of these reasons
right cool there's lots of people who
are like that too right
and where are they going to go
who are they turning to what resources
uh maybe they know Tony Robbins and they
happen to go and go to YouTube and
search right but maybe not and maybe
they say stuck or maybe something really
you know worse happens right your story
could be the first step for them to say
here's what happened for me I got I
watched some videos I did want to go to
a group but I knew I needed to to not
die
and so videos started to help me and
then I created a really regimented
morning routine because if I didn't have
that down then I would be
I would be stuck and now I don't need to
have as regimented it doesn't take me
four hours every day I can do it unless
cool but it's like it's not where you
are now and what your schedule is now
like Evan from five years ago could not
handle your your what you're doing now
right so that's not what you're trying
to teach
you teach the first step
if I could convey anything it really is
the
you're never too old and it's never too
late and that you can rebuild you can
come out the other side of it
you have to you have to you know I I
guess have have the goals and the
visions and the dreams
but keep them there and realize that you
have to do today and and
it's scary and it's hard and there was a
lot of times that I did want to quit and
I did want to give up and I didn't want
to keep going in different areas and I
see so many people
they say they want to do it or they
start and then they stop and then they
fail and then you'll see them go right
back to where they were and that is what
I think um
I think that's what gets me the most is
because like I know you can do it I know
that it's possible like I'm proof that
it's possible and then I see people that
try one or two things and then they fail
like it breaks my heart to actually see
it you know but when I was in the midst
of it you do feel hopeless you feel
helpless like there's just everybody's
Rock Bottom they would say is the worst
you know you weren't as bad as me or you
know that whole comparison and um
knowing what it's like if I could do
anything it would be to stop people from
getting to that moment
um
and unfortunately I think a lot of
people have to get to that moment so my
thought is if I could help people from
the rebuilding stage it might be enough
for the person that's on that down slide
to say well I don't want to get to where
he did or whatever enough to have some
self-awareness for them to make the
decision to try to seek help because I
don't think me talking to somebody to
just talk to somebody isn't going to
stop them from hitting that that low
but by seeing the other side of it it
might be enough for them to want to not
continue on that downward slide so I
think the opportunity is showing coming
out the other side showing that growth
in the different areas
but it still comes down to that internal
conflict of like well I'm not yet where
I want to be so who am I to tell you
what you need to do to become who you
want to be in The Logical I do
understand that logical side of like
growth is a never-ending process
um
so pardon me you know kind of feels a
little bit hypocritical of like do as I
say not as I've not been able to do but
you don't need to tell anybody what to
do right
you have to tell them anything you don't
you can only you can first off hold
space and listen and you're a great
listener
people tell you things that they may not
tell other people because you listen and
you don't judge them and you don't say
oh you did that oh my God like you are
open and accepting and people I'm sure
tell you things that they haven't told
their spouses or anybody else in their
life already that is value just having
somebody to talk to who's not judging
them for what they're going through is
already tremendous value
then when you're when you're helping you
don't even have to say well you need to
go do this this all you have to do is
share your story of what worked for you
and then it's up to them if they want to
take the advice or not right so you
don't have to be like when I said hey
this isn't prescriptive but here's what
worked for me it gives an inspiration
and hope and maybe that works for you
and you run with it or maybe you take a
piece of it and tweak and go do
something else but you don't have to
worry about being like you need to go do
this
and hold yourself to that perfect
standard because maybe you gave the
wrong advice like no I'm sharing my
story I'm not a doctor I'm not a
therapist yours will work for me
and these other things that and maybe
it'll work for you and you're always in
your truth because you're just sharing
your story and what else
and trying to tell the best story that
most relates to the person that's in
front of you
I think for you honestly like you thrive
when you're with people
and when you're just by yourself for too
long thinking about content you
overthink it and like how am I going to
do it and then nothing happens and then
like the occasional Instagram posters
and if nothing happens so it's like and
who am I but like if you were actually
helping people and you see that by
having a conversation with you
even if you weren't able to give a
specific piece of advice they just leave
more hopeful now because you talk to
them and you listen to them and you
understood them
I think that's what will help keep the
whether it's a dopamine ongoing or just
a belief or the motivation that this
thing has something because I met you
what three years ago when was Pittsburgh
three years ago
and you're still the same guy of like
helping and caring and kind and trying
to listen and always bring back to the
people but it's never turned into it's
like these little start and stop and
start and stop and start and stop and I
think the missing piece hasn't been the
the how it's been there's a lack of
connection to people you don't see it
working like when somebody sends you a
hundred dollars because you your
Instagram posts change their life or
whatever you remember that right it's
like it's uh it's a great win right but
like there's not enough of them there's
not enough of it happening ongoing
but if that was happening every day not
that it's a revenue model I have 100
bucks but uh
that wasn't for me it was a pay it
forward to find someone in a community
to give it to so just well right I don't
think like I wasn't mine yeah but
whatever like yeah yeah yeah as a result
of you posted something that became so
you became a part of their Journey right
kind of like I was for you with the
videos I didn't know who you were like
you may not have had a deep personal
connection with this person but they
loved your content and decided hey
here's a hundred bucks do something with
it they pay it forward awesome like if
that stuff was happening more regularly
or you'd like could meet somebody in
person and help them like for me I love
this more than
making videos by myself at home in my
studio press and record even though
those are easier to make this is more
fun because interaction yeah you get to
see like you're helping somebody right
right
I think that's the biggest missing piece
for you is you don't see enough when you
come to an event like this or I'm sure
at Tony's event you're like helping all
the people around you
[Laughter]
maybe some I'm I would bet that somebody
got more value at Tony's event by being
with you than by listening to what Tony
said
just from just from who you are maybe
whether you would accept that or not I'm
sure like that app
and so it's okay how do you create a
system then where you are around that
more consistently right so you can feel
the the results the impact of the work
that you're doing not on uh even because
you got a 2 000 views on a video it
doesn't it doesn't hit the same dopamine
Rush
as somebody saying Evan dude you changed
my life thank you right
I think that's been the biggest missing
thing over the past three years is you
just don't feel feel enough of the
connection to the work right and then
you just get in your head and
what's the point overthinking and I
could do this and that and this and that
and then nothing happens because the
business always takes priority and is
paying the bills and it's and you get
connection through the company and the
meeting the people and you end up
helping people in your business in their
life where where the dichotomy is and it
took me a long time I I actually figured
this out with my therapist is for years
um and people with addiction usually you
try to
get that fulfillment the dopamine
external things I always chase the
result whether it was money it was the
car it was the the whatever and
um
but you can figure out what that it is
and based on your own numbers and
performance and you know how you do your
job you can reverse engineer the numbers
of like what you need to do how many
people I need to talk to you how many do
you have to pitch how many do you have
to close what's the average sale going
to be you you can
you know reverse engineer the numbers to
get to your goal and I'm very good at
that
but I never had fulfillment from that
and I I found that in hindsight that uh
I don't know who says it but it's a
great I I
don't know who it was but it's um
you know we we tend to work to our quota
not to our potential and
for me even hitting my quota was still
most times was still better than
everybody else around me sure you hit a
quota and you're at the top and you feel
great about that but deep down inside
you know you have more in you but by
doing more to try to get to your
potential you could fail and if you do
that you're going to fail big in front
of everybody so you're going to go from
being the best
to failing in front of people
that's why I loved the Iron Man because
it was and I was public about it or the
half Ironman
um I'm gonna do the full Iron Man this
year
um that I was putting myself out there
that like
I can't if I don't finish everybody will
see it but if I do finish I will know
that I went to my potential not just a
quota I could have went and did a
shorter event which is more than what
most people did and you know beat my
chest for it but inside I knew I would
have more when I finished this this half
when I was done it was hard but it
wasn't that hard I knew I had more so
I'm like I have to do a full so
you know from that
Corporate America Job shiny object
reverse engineer numbers never gave me
the Fulfillment but now I find myself
shifting and this is why I talk my
therapist about I'm finding myself drawn
more towards the thought leadership
World wanting to help people where
you're dealing with emotions and
vulnerability which is not something
I've been really good good at because
throughout my life I've been very closed
off not letting people in just it's a
self-preservation or so defense
mechanism whatever
and um but to be in this space
you don't know what the final product is
you're trying to get because if it's an
internal fulfillment if it's a feeling
you can't quantify that and if you can't
quantify it you can't reverse engineer
it so my mind is wired numbers
but like my heart is going more towards
the the helping and serving but you
can't map that out to break down steps
so it's like an it's like a it's like a
dichotomy I hear you
but you kind of can in that
the feeling of fulfillment that you're
chasing
how many times when you've been in a
room with a lot of people or just with
one person that you've helped do you
leave feeling
more fulfilled
often so that's how you quantify it
put you in a room with somebody who
needs help
and you'll eighty percent of the time
come out with more fulfillment that's
what I said like that's the missing
piece because you're not feeling the
connection you're all push push push and
no hugs like you need the feeling
because okay I had a thousand Instagram
followers now two thousand or whatever
it is like it doesn't mean enough
because it's a momentary you cross that
number but there's no heart
the heart is when you're talking and
you're actually very good at you say I'm
all you're not just all mine you're
great at connecting to people and
helping them
you do it naturally
more than anybody on my whole tour
we did in every city I went across
America you were like the most the only
guy who didn't talk about himself and
like used his time to help the other
people
so you're naturally great at it you're
just not putting yourself in the
position to do it
and so you can XO quantify it if you
were to
twice a week do something with somebody
else who needs help
80 of the time you're going to come out
feeling more fulfilled like I'm I'm
Kick-Ass at what I do I'm so happy that
I had that conversation with that person
because you're actually good at it and
it's like if you sucked at it then that
might be 25 but you're actually really
good at it so 80 90 of the time you're
going to come out feeling more fulfilled
which then gives you the courage and the
motivation to then stay consistent
because you're all push but there's no
consistency when you can match the push
and the hug then you'll stay consistent
because you're you feel that it's
fulfilling
if you're not fulfilled you won't stay
consistent
it's just little thing to chase like I'm
going to start and stop and start and
stop right if you actually felt
fulfilled in the work like this is
Meaningful this was really cool I want
to do it again you'll stay more
consistent on all the work that's why I
I probably stopped about eight months
ago
um
consistently posting or creating or
whatever because I felt like well what's
the point nobody's seeing it and it's
not being done to and I know what you're
going to say yeah but even before that
eight months ago stop you stopped before
that too yeah over the past three years
it's been like two months on three
months off four months on eight months
off it's like it's just been this
constant you actually watch that stuff
starting stuff you know I don't watch
all of it but I stay I try to stay in
tune
but what's what's missing in all of your
content is like there's never anybody
else it's just you sharing and your
biggest wins are when somebody gives you
a good comment when somebody says hey
Evan that was really meaningful they
give you the hundred dollar thank you or
whatever right that's like what the
hundred dollars meant more than you than
than getting some deal that might be a
million dollars right it's like somebody
valued what I was saying right so you
need to engineer and whether it's even
getting somebody to help I might have
somebody who might be able to help you
like book guests but
you need to be in positions where you're
meeting people ideally face to face and
because I haven't had community that has
been a struggle for me on finding the
opportunity to talk to people or how to
get into groups or
um events to do it I have friends that
have are part of community they speak on
a regular basis but because I'm not part
of that community and those things
that's not really a stage that I can get
on so I do want to get in front of
people but it could be you just have to
start doing it and that path has been
done I have to find it or I have to
create it somewhere to actually get in
front of people face to face so
um but I can't go to the venues where my
friends do because I'm not I didn't do
that program so I can't go do that so
that's been a challenge for me is
actually finding the venue or the place
or the platform to do that because if I
could do anything that's what I would be
doing but but how much effort has gone
into actually figuring that out right
not as much as should be should have so
but that's the answer that's what you do
right or you can have your own show
right like I have a Booker like how did
you get here I didn't I didn't ask you
to be here no I kind of did a little bit
like make sure everyone gets a special
message but but like my team reached out
and said hey we're doing this thing do
you want to do you want to come right
and when they asked me who to put on
it's like anybody who's been with Movie
Makers over a year but make sure you
reach out to admin because he's been
asking for this for a while so it's GPS
available right you could have somebody
help you and if somebody in mind who
might be able to help you but you could
or you have some in your team who is
booking times for you to meet people and
make content and I haven't done that
um to get to to get support with that
from content creation from anything it's
it's kind of just been
yeah but you don't necessarily need this
whole setup but you could like you could
do right you could do a day a month and
film a whole bunch of content and hire
local film crew to come out who's in
Pittsburgh and film content with you and
you could hire somebody to book guests
for you to come on and and like today I
don't know what I don't know what we're
talking about hey man how can I help and
you give me something man when we talk
about it and I'm going to leave feeling
fulfilled right and and I think that's
where it comes back to like well who am
I to do it and I get it we've covered it
and I understand that but you won't even
like that those kinds of questions pop
into your head when you're in your head
because when someone is in front of you
and you're helping them you're not
thinking who am I to do this well I
guess it's basically the okay one
you're inviting somebody that either you
don't know or you do know and then to
sit down and say well how can I help and
if it's somebody that you do know
they're going to be like well I know you
you can't help me or if it's somebody
you don't know it's well how are you
qualified to help me so why would I tell
you what you can help me with what I'm
saying is when you actually sit down and
talk to somebody
how many times do great things come
where they're going to leave
having a lesson or action or at least
more belief in themselves right 80 of
the time right 90 of the time what like
what feels right to you
it's not 20 of the time no it's a pretty
high number yeah right
so all of those thoughts go away when
you're just in front of somebody
so I just got to find ways to get in
front of people yeah and like and then
commit to somebody else like you commit
to a Booker to say okay book me somebody
to come in like I had to show up here
because you guys were hearing because
because I I got Danny to show up and
film I'm not going to not show up now
what if I can't add value oh my God
Evan's coming in from Pittsburgh Aaron
Cuts flying in from Dubai to be here
what if I can't help yeah even if I'm
thinking about it doesn't matter because
I committed and now we're here
right so you just need to commit to
having somebody help you find the people
whether you want to do it just at your
office in a simple setup or you want to
hire a film crew for the day to film
with you
um
but that's that's the only thing that's
missing and all those all those thoughts
go away they're all legit like yes I
think those things too
but they all go away once you start
talking to them once they're in front of
you and they say I I don't know how to
accept myself I don't know how to
whatever
then it just you get into Flow State and
you know it's actually it's actually
funny because the last three weeks I've
kind of Taken on a new Venture with um
some people business-wise and I have
been so busy for I mean I don't even
know what's going on in the world like I
couldn't tell you news I couldn't tell
you anything because the last probably
three weeks has been non-stop it's been
14 hour days and 16 whatever and I love
it and it's amazing because like
when you don't have time to think you
just do yeah and when I have so many
things to do like I perform better when
I don't have time to think like I know
that I recognize that because I will
over analyze and I you know I mean I
it's interesting because from a
personality test my number one trade is
I'm a risk taker
um recognition accolades was number two
money was number three
and um
but from a business standpoint
I advise people against risk how to
protect themselves and and whatever so
it again I don't know it's kind of weird
but I've been so busy that I just
haven't had time to think and the
results have been great and business is
great and you know income goes up
so to your point of like the activity
when you're doing it things just
continue to happen so I do understand
that but it's that starting point and I
guess it's that that lack of commitment
that I've probably had to do it
our self-doubt or yeah I mean honestly
in your work I would say you give people
you give people an option and help them
protect against the doubt like the most
risked adverse way like you give them
downside protection right so they can go
be risky
right because you've helped them solve
this right I think you actually enable
people to live a better life and and go
chase down their dreams because you've
given them this thing that's going to
protect them against the worst case
scenario right so I don't think you're
actually teaching people to be risk
adverse you're teaching people how to
predict the downside so they can go and
live more after your life right minimize
your loss of risk yeah so that you can
go in and go live your life yeah I think
all of it goes away when you just are
with somebody and that's been the
biggest missing thing over the past
three years you won't be once you're in
a conversation you won't be saying I
don't know if I can help this person I
don't know if I'm like I don't know if
I'm good enough it all go away because
you're just helping them activity yeah
so you need to but with somebody
activity with people who you're helping
so you need somebody if you're not gonna
do the work you need somebody to book
people to come on your show or to talk
to them and to film it so you have
content going up and you you'll have you
might have anxiety the morning another
like oh my God what am I doing I can't
believe to meet these people
and then you're gonna go there it's
gonna be amazing you're going to leave
say this is the this is the greatest
thing ever people's what I do yeah like
that that is all your content is solo
right right no I I I don't have any
hesitation to do it I don't have any you
have lots of hesitation to do it no no
I'm saying like if if I had the
opportunity to walk on a stage in front
of 5 000 people that wouldn't bother me
to do it like I don't I don't get gun
shy with it I don't but it's
that's not even the most meaningful word
though no no I know but I'm saying as
far as people and talking and speaking
like I don't have any problem with that
it's about figuring out
how to actually get in front of the
people to do it and and like you said
there there's small local I haven't put
the legwork in to even find the local
this or local I'm not connected to my
Booker who like books people from my
shows who might be a fit for you but
it's it's I would I would delegate it to
somebody
because you're going to start looking
for different shows different places to
go to and then you're going to get back
into like who am I going to be here I
didn't go to a I don't know and then
Adele dies again
delegated to somebody just like you
hired your trainer to help you with your
Triathlon you hire somebody and that's
their focus to go off and do this thing
to the book guest for you to come and
Coach to book stages for you to go and
speak at even local so that it's now
it's decided like that's the greatest
action you can take from this trip is
like delegate it to somebody because you
will not stay consistent on it right so
that has to be somebody else's job but
then they're going to force you to stay
consistent because you you will not turn
down if you are speaking at this event
you're going to show up
and then you're going to leave super
fulfilled like I'm this is kick-ass as
far as you said that when I had to
rebuild my my business and everything
um I had to start over solo by myself
and I had to do a lot of the stuff that
I hated to do I'm not a sit-down kind of
guy that's a whole other topic of the
medicated the ADHD and all that stuff
and I had to force myself to do that and
you'd have lazy days and you know just
not doing what you're supposed to do and
and then you know when I hired I have a
really good assistant now
and she does exactly what you said like
what's next what's next what's next and
having that person hold you accountable
always having something in front of you
and I'm sure that's why it hasn't worked
on the other side too um
you know and I guess I don't really have
an excuse for that other than just I
never have made the time to do it maybe
out of fear that it wouldn't work or
not having full confidence in what the
process would be not being able to
control and reverse engineer those
numbers finding myself and more of a
place of um faith
if you will of that it'll just work or
faith in my own abilities or maybe it's
more of a but it's all I thinking I
believe from my own abilities right and
that's what I'm saying so it's like you
have to give it to somebody
okay hire somebody all introducing
somebody but or or hire somebody local
or give it to your assistant say I want
to be on stages talking about this stuff
I'll speak it I'll speak at schools I'll
speak at YMCAs I'll speak at Lions Clubs
I'll speak at industry associations
they'll speak at anything we'll get to
come and share my story
and I want to do a show where people
come in and I I help them and we're
going to film it and make some content
and that's part of the deal
I guess Legacy I think to sum it up like
if I could do anything I would like to
I would like to have a message out there
that would help people long after I'm
gone
because I think the problem that I faced
and that I went through is never going
to go away
um I think people are always going to
struggle and it's not about it's not
about the addiction the drugs the
alcohol or whatever somebody might do
it's about the underlying issues that
caused and triggered and that we all
have something somewhere and it's about
do you or don't you have the ability to
deal with and some people they can face
adversity and work their way through it
and they have the support systems or
whatever other people just don't have
that or
whatever their demons are you know and
um
that's something that's it's always
going to be out there and I think if I
could rid the world of one thing it
would be that
um because I know how it feels to feel
helpless you're unintentionally
destroying your life even though you
know you're destroying your life and the
very thing you're doing you think it's
making you feel better but you know it's
making you worse but yet you continue to
do it and it's just a cycle and and you
don't think you're ever going to get off
of it and most people just give up you
know and when you give up you don't deal
with the demons that's why there's such
a high relapse rate is because people
will go detox will get the medical
attention they'll do whatever but they
don't do that deep psychological work
they don't address the demons they don't
address their their vulnerabilities or
their insecurities
because in order to do that you have to
admit to yourself that you're not
perfect you have to admit that you're
flawed that you know you might not have
all the answers that you're not as good
as you think or say that you are and it
takes a lot to get to that point and
unfortunately that's you usually the
moment of worse that's where you know
you contemplate the unthinkable you know
because you just don't see a way out of
it and a lot of people don't get out of
that situation and you know I just try I
want to leave a legacy of like I know it
can always be worse
but I think from where I was the only
worse could be is I wouldn't be here you
know and I know what it's like to
destroy everything and to lose
everything and to to contemplate that
and then decide like no I want to live
and I you know for me personally from a
faith standpoint I this is where I kind
of feel empty is I promised God that if
you help me get through this and get
healthy I will spend the rest of my life
trying to help other people either from
making the mistakes I made or that it's
possible to rebuild your life after not
in the middle
um in whatever way that I can and I'm
not feeling I'm not holding up my end of
that promise yet
and I feel very hypocritical because of
it so like I got my life back and I'm
getting all the spoils and benefits and
the fruits of it
but I'm not doing what I said to be able
to help other people on the scale that I
want to
and that makes me feel very hypocritical
you know and I haven't been able
to figure it out as much as I've wanted
to and I think it's because I still have
my own insecurities and my own doubts my
own you know my own struggles I have to
deal with I can't get too involved with
people because I still have to maintain
my own sobriety and I'm still doing my
own therapy and things like that so I
can only take it so far
um
but that's kind of where I struggle
because it's just it's individual but
it's Collective yeah you know same
I don't use the word attic because
people can get funny about that it's
like alcoholic and then you have addicts
and I mean it's one of the same it's
addiction but you know you're saying
like you know
same attic different story or
different stories you know it's kind of
like every everybody's separate but
equal right and I mean that that's
that's kind of what I'm going for it
just it bothers me I haven't done it yet
I think it's a great point to end on man
now you got to do the work keep that
promise thank you and go hire that
person
to see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe
see you there